what's the deal with airplane peanuts
peanuts Matt Rife is one of the fastest
growing comedians in the world at age 27
he already has a whopping 14 million
Tick Tock followers a harem of Die Hard
fans at every show and is now gearing up
for a brand new 120 show World Tour
complete with an Ashton Kutcher and Mila
Kunis promo video wish to go on a date
with Mila Kunis if she's so
cat Rife but in 2023 most would argue
there's nobody killing it harder and
Matt Rife has quickly become a household
name amongst comedy fans and comedians
this might be the most handsome young
man in comedy right now and Matt Ryan
and the two people that are fighting for
dominance of the LA comedy scene right
now are literally indistinguishable from
each other which is weird and it's me
and Matt Rife
so what it really is is this fight
between these two brothers who are the
same yes to try to try to reach these
people Jesus Christ is this what Matt
looks like yeah that's what I look like
too it's these cameras you don't have
nice cameras so it's hard to that's what
La is right now it's just me and this
guy yeah fighting for Supremacy yeah so
how did all of this happen so quickly
for Matt Rife and what's the big problem
that people seem to have with his new
tour the viral success story of Matt
Rife can be traced back to two main
factors being stage time and crowd work
most comedians begin their careers
getting on stage for the first time in
their early 20s if they're lucky and
usually have about 10 years of learning
the ropes and perfecting their crafts
through many ups and downs leading up to
hitting their stride as a known comedian
sometime in their 30s then farther
developing from there to hopefully be
playing the biggest venues possible by
their 40s Matt Rife did things
differently his stand-up career began at
the young age of 15. this unbelievably
Early Head Start is what allows Matt to
be seemingly way ahead of schedule at
age 27. most Comics his age have a few
years of experience Max under their belt
but Matt Rife has 12. while majority of
27 year old comedians are either just
starting or getting time as opening or
feature acts Matt Rife just announced
one of the biggest comedy tours we'll
see from anyone this whole year
regardless of age now before we get into
the one issue with his world tour and
the reason that some people are outraged
there's one more key factor in Matt
rife's wild Journey to the top and that
is the beautiful art of crowd work
he didn't
he didn't do anything he didn't do
anything wrong
in life
did he not have a job the entire time
together
he did
he works in the ER also you broke up
with a hero
four million followers on Instagram is
insane just to put that into context
with some other big name comedians Matt
Rife has more followers than Bill Burr
John Mulaney Theo Von Tom segora Andrew
Schultz and eight times as many
followers as Shane Gillis in fact the
only comedian that I could find with
more followers than Matt Rife is none
other than Joe Rogan now obviously
follower amount does not equal funniness
but it does put into context the insane
amount of popularity currently
surrounding Matt Rife over the last few
years we've seen multiple Comics blow up
online through the use of crowd work
Clips whether it be Stavros Sam Morel or
even Andrew Schultz who famously started
the whole clip game by posting one video
every single week for a year posting
crowd work Clips helped all these guys
gain some popularity in the comedy space
and sell tickets on the road but it's
still nothing compared to the perfect
internet storm that hit Matt Wright
which is it just all of One Clip just
blew up everything it was so weird it
was one clip yeah a video I thought was
stupid and didn't want to post anyways I
was like this isn't even funny a young
handsome comedian's highly sex actual
and funny crowd work clip goes viral
reaching audiences on the internet that
never in a million years would have
stepped foot in a comedy club unless
dragged by their boyfriends Now Matt is
the young attractive male comedian that
just got introduced to an entire
untapped Market of fans a brand new
demographic for comedy that overlaps
with one of the most obsessive and
hive-minded groups of people in the
world young single white women who wear
diapers to Taylor Swift concerts and
don't mind paying 500 for tickets in
fact this world tour is already sold out
in most places and any remaining tickets
are priced so insanely high that Matt
Rife might currently be comedy's Taylor
Swift if that's even a thing it's great
he's getting this many new eyeballs on
stand-up and hats off the Matt Rife for
the brand new tour but it is a little
Bittersweet for any fans of his comedy
that just wanted to go see him perform
jokes but now can't because the ticket
price was set by bachelorette parties
and girls that want to bring him teddy
bears
for me
why it's a voice message too in it it
has a voice message
oh my God so I did I did a tick tock one
time where the girl in the audience was
saying it was a red flag that a guy
brought her a Build-A-Bear on first date
and I had said in the video I was like I
would love if somebody brought me a
building bar so you brought me one yeah
I got to do more jokes about getting my
dick sucked
foreign
guest spots from last week Theo Vaughn
was the guest on The Joe Rogan
Experience your mom's house had on
Stavros Chris DiStefano was on Dr Drew
after dark Chrissy was also the guest on
we might be drunk kill Tony this week
was with Eleanor Kerrigan Sam Morel was
on to take your shoes off with Rick
Glassman whiskey Ginger talked with Tom
Papa Chrissy chaos had on Moses storm
and two bears one cave was Tom and Tim
Dillon so four people have ended up in
the lake dead someone's having fun
someone's out there doing it no foul
play why would they even say that
they're just trying to keep people
they're trying to keep because they
don't want to hurt the tourism yeah of
people coming to Austin they're like we
got F1 coming up guys yeah they're like
we don't want we don't want to
discourage people from going out on that
vomit colored Lake we don't want people
thinking bad things come of that listen
some people just tripped and they fell
and they drowned and I fell in the lake
and now he's with Jesus now anyway get
on the raft
he's with Jesus now get a taco and get
on the ramp we gotta build more
Apartments
this body count could just keep growing
they'd just be like listen yeah people
die every day what do you guys want it's
only 37 people who cares with the
hottest city in America you think a
couple of dead people in a lake matters
and I think In fairness to them I think
these people that died were bartenders
or people that were very replaceable
have you
this past weekend with the Yvonne head
on Trevor Wallace flagrant announced
Andrew Schultz's first ever arena show
in Toronto Andrew Santino was the guest
on the Harland Highway taste buds
battled bacon and eggs versus breakfast
cereal Ali Sadiq was a guest on the
Honeydew Roy Wood Jr was on Ru garbage
Howie Mandel was on the blocks podcast
and Michael Roland was on you know what
dude are you tired of nagging back pain
mental fogginess and restless nights of
sleep it might be time to give the
pranamat acupressure Matt set a try this
spiky matte and spiky pillow combo could
just be the answer to all of your
questions just look at the numbers after
just 15 minutes of regular use 97 of
customers confirmed their back tension
subsided 80 of respondents felt their
headache easer completely disappear and
95 percent confirmed better quality of
sleep how does this work
products 10 000 spikes increased blood
flow from the very first minute of use
your skin and muscles receive more
oxygen so that every single cell in your
body benefits improving overall
metabolism and fighting inflammation all
while stimulating the body's natural
healing processes if any of these
benefits sound good to you and you might
be able to benefit from having a Prana
mat in your life go check out the
description of this video right now and
use code world at checkout for our
special offer that's World spell wrld
as far as brand new comedy specials are
either out right now or coming out soon
Ali Sadiq domino effect part 2 came out
last week on his YouTube channel it's a
follow-up to last year's special domino
effect which is an hour and 20 minutes
long so if you love sinking into long
long specials these are perfect for you
other new specials out right now on
YouTube Drew Lynch Shortcake came out a
few days ago as well as Jeremiah Watkins
new crowd work documentary the last riff
and Brian holtzman's new special cancel
Holtzman is out on YouTube right now as
well Bob thinks the Earth is flat
hey Bob you're a [__] [__]
and these people who who believe in
extra systems
you know what I'm talking about
right speak like this because I didn't
go to preschool another recent big
comedy event the kill Tony 10-year
anniversary live stream took place last
night if you'd like to see some behind
the scenes footage from their biggest
show ever we just posted a video about
it a few days ago it includes some dope
interviews with some of the comedians
who performed that night and a few kill
Tony fans as well that video will be on
the end screen of this video in a few
seconds if you want to check it out
thank you for watching please subscribe
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]